you were just in Miami but you were also
uh recently honored in Miami right I was
yeah how was that um I was honored with
my with a statue I know so that's crazy
yes thank you it's a bronze statue of
you did you have any input on this
statue by the way I do I do I I knew
before uh the audience knew um I had to
sit down with with the heat but um it
was great to share it in Miami with the
audience with the with with the fan base
that's been there like that statue is
all of our statue all are invested in
the Miami putting that statue up and so
the fact that it's going to happen later
this year it's going to be pretty cool
so yeah of course I'm excited and all
the things but it's kind of weird too
like there's a statue of who thinks you
like you what's a statue I don't know
it's not many people have one right like
I know like monuments I don't know like
like you know like it's not I'm alive
and so I'm alive you know what I mean I
am not dead yet no like normally like
when you think of you think of monuments
I'm alive so and I'm like 42 and I'm
like wow I'm getting a statue like I
feel like I should be older in my life I
feel every time you go to Miami though
you have to take a picture with that cuz
you are alive I told them like was like
I was asking them like what are people
what are you guys going to do at night
time when people want to come and enjoy
themselves by my statue yeah light it up
yeah and they was like well we may have
security may not I was like well I'm
talking about myself like I may come at
like 2: in the morning like be like damn
I got a statue yeah bring my music you
know do my Tik toks in front of my own
statue exactly or your podcast or my
podcast right out there here's the why I
got to statue
yeah welcome to the wide yeah welcome to
the Wi right behind me I got a statue I
want a
[Music]
[Applause]
statue thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home